So that ends the introduction
to tracking.
Basically saying that what we're
going to do is use a model to make
predictions.
Take some measurements,
and, integrate it.
Like I said, it's not strictly computer
vision, because it involves state
estimation, which comes from all
sorts of parts of engineering and
robotics and things like that.
But it's what's required in order
to make the tracking to work.
So well, we'll sort of take a little
bit of a detour to talk about
state dynamics and estimation.
Little bit of robot localization
using visual features and
then we'll get back to fundamentals
of tracking using these methods.
Cool.